Researchers in China have developed a ‘smart
coating’ that behaves like skin, heals itself
from damage, and is as hard as tooth enamel.
The future is here, everyone, the future is
here.
This development represents a big step forward
in materials science, but self-healing isn’t
exactly new tech.There are three main general
types of self-healing tech available right
now :
One where the healing agents are embedded
in the material…
One where a vascular network--kind of like
your body’s veins--brings healing agents
to the site of damage...
And one where the material is intrinsically
capable of healing itself when exposed to
a certain stimuli, like heat.
Some use ionic conduction, some use covalent
bonding and conductive silver nanoparticles,
and one of my favorites is a team in China
that takes inspiration from the human body.
Say your phone screen cracks.
With something like this new technology, the
softer, cushy bottom layer reacts to the trauma
and provides material to fill in the broken
bits of the top layer, while the hardness
of the top layer provides a protective coating
to allow the ‘healing’ to take place.
The harder top layer is also apparently antimicrobial,
meaning it could have future implications
for biomedical devices--self-healing cyborg
implants, anyone!?
Not for me, but you go for it.
Other teams around the world have been exploring
similar technologies.
In just the last few years we’ve seen the
beginnings of soft, self-healing robots that
can perform delicate tasks and fit into small
spaces.
And, flexible, self-healing ‘electronic
skin’ that could attach to a person’s
body and monitor their health, as well as
a whole host of other potential applications,
in human-robot interaction and prosthetic
limb enhancement.
These most recent developments are also recyclable,
which means that while they’re a promising
new technology, they don’t promise to create
a lot of excess waste in the process.
One particularly exciting breakthrough came
2016 when a team published research demonstrating
a material that was conductive, stretchy,
AND self-healing, providing major implications
for extending the life of lithium-ion batteries.
The big takeaway from this topic is not just
a science-fiction-like tech advancement, but
also major environmental implications--imagine,
never having a broken electronic that you
had to replace, because the one you have is
self-healing!?
The top layer of this new coating from the
Chinese researchers is so hard and durable,
the team hopes that their self-healing technology
will last longer and produce less waste than
options that may wear out faster after fewer
injuries.
But that’s getting a little ahead of ourselves.
For now, the Chinese engineering team is trying
to improve their production process to make
it more efficient and less expensive, so that
they can hopefully bring a commercial prototype
to market in the next few years.
They say it would likely be applicable in
areas like consumer electronics, and maybe
even construction.
Self-healing buildings would be pretty sweet.
We may still be a couple of years aways from
seeing self-healing technologies in stores
or in the doctor’s office, and when they
do come around experts say consumers are going
to have to pay a premium, ‘cause dat’s
gon be ‘spensive.
But it’s exciting to see researchers taking
the longevity of their technology and the
environmental impact of any potential products
into account.
Hey peeps--For more about our robotic future,
check out this video about microbots that
go inside you--Yeah!
And fun fact: researchers aren’t just inspired
by nature, they’re actually mixing living
organisms INTO their designs.
Like, with a new bio-concrete that contains
a bacteria that can stay dormant for up to
200 years.
When activated by water, the bacteria produce
limestone to fix the crack.
Oh bacteria, I love you.
Thanks for watching Seeker.